HIS OWN INAUGURATION DAY IF
ELECTED.
BRET?
>> THANKS, PETER.
WE’RE TALKING WITH THE TOP MEDIA
REPRESENTATIVES FOR EACH OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
FIRST UP, T.J. DUCKLOW FOR THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
THANKS FOR BEING ON.
>> THANKS, BRET.
>> WE WANT THE START WITH WHAT
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
SPECIFICALLY WOULD HAVE DONE IN
JANUARY HAD HE RECEIVED THE
BRIEFING THAT THE PRESIDENT
RECEIVED.
>> SURE.
HERE WE ARE IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
WE’RE 4% OF THE WORLD’S
POPULATION.
WE’RE 20% OF THE COVID CASES.
25% OF THE COVID DEATHS.
WE KNOW FROM BOB WOODWARD’S
REPORTING AS YOU COVERED THAT
THIS PRESIDENT KNOWINGLY AND
WILLFULLY LIED ABOUT THE
DANGEROUSNESS OF THE THREAT THAT
FACED THIS COUNTRY.
WE KNOW FROM COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
HAD THIS PRESIDENT TAKEN AS A
FEW WEEKS EARLIER, WE WOULD HAVE
HAD TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN SAVED.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT WAS CALLING
IT A HOAX, SAYING THE VIRUS
WOULD DISAPPEAR, HE KNEW, BRET,
HE KNEW HOW DANGEROUS THE THREAT
THAT WE’RE FACING WAS.
JOE BIDEN FROM THE VERY BEGIN
BEGINNING IN MARCH PUT OUT CLEAR
PANS --
>> HERE’S HIS TWO TOP ADVISERS
THAT HE LISTENS TO CLOSELY ON
JANUARY 28th AND JANUARY 30th.
>> WOULD YOU BAN CHINESE
TRAVELERS FROM ARRIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> I WOULDN’T.
I THINK THAT’S PREMATURE.
>> EVERYONE IN AMERICA SHOULD
TAKE A VERY BIG BREATH, SLOW
DOWN AND STOP PANICKING AND
BEING HYSTERICAL.
>> IT GOES ON.
THEY SAY THAT MASKS ARE NOT
NECESSARY, THIS IS OVERREACTION.
GOES INTO FEBRUARY AND EARLY
MARCH.
THOSE ARE THE OPINION HE LISTENS
TO.
JOE BIDEN HAS SAID THAT HE
WOULDN’T HAVE CLOSED THE TRAVEL
FROM CHINA.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WOULD THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT HAVE DONE?
>> LET’S GET A FEW THINGS
STRAIGHT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS NOT
AGAINST THE TRAVEL BAN.
LET’S REMEMBER --
>> HE WASN’T --
>> LET’S REMEMBER AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION.
DONALD TRUMP WAS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT WAS ON DONALD TRUMP --
>> I’M ASKING YOU IF JOE BIDEN
WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, IF HE WAS --
>> -- TAKE ACTION --
>> HE CLOSED THE DOOR TO CHINA.
>> JOE BIDEN WROTE AN OP-ED
WARNING THIS WAS COMING.
WHAT DID DONALD TRUMP DO?
TRUMP WAS PRAISING CHINA.
HE WAS PRAISING PRESIDENT XI’S
RESPONSE.
SAYING THAT THEY HAD IT UNDER
CONTROL.
THEY DIDN’T HAVE IT UNDER
>> OKAY.
LET ME CLARIFY.
>> -- PLANS TO CONFRONT --
>> I UNDERSTAND.
YOU SAY THAT JOE BIDEN WAS FOR
CLOSING DOWN TRAVEL FROM CHINA
WHEN THE PRESIDENT DID IT?
>> JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT
HE WAS NOT AGAINST THAT TRAVEL
BAN.
>> HE WAS FOR IT?
>> JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN CLEAR
ABOUT THIS, BRET.
AGAIN, I CAN SEND YOU THE FACT
CHECKS IF THEY’RE HELPFUL.
THIS HAS BEEN FACT CHECKED TO
OBLIVION
OBLIVION.
>> YOU SAY YES, HE WAS FOR THE
TRAVEL BAN 48 HOURS AFTER
RECEIVING THAT BRIEFING, YES OR
NO.
>> I KNOW YOU LIKE TO CITE THE
TRAVEL BAN --
>> THE PRESIDENT DOES.
IT WILL BE IN THE DEBATE.
>> THE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THE
TRAVEL BAN, EVEN AFTER THE
PRESIDENT IMPLEMENTED THE TRAVEL
BAN, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
CANED --
>> I’M GOING TO TAKE IT YOU’RE
NOT GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
YOU’RE GOING TO SEND ME FACT
CHECKSES.
>> WHAT WAS PRESIDENT --
>> LET’S CONTINUE TO FACT CHECK.
HERE’S WHAT DR. FAUCI SAID.
WHEN ASKED IF THERE WAS A
DISCREPANCY OF WHAT HE SAID
PRIVATELY AND PUBLICLY.
>> I MAY NOT BE TUNED IN TO WHAT
THEY’RE TALKING ANT.
I DIDN’T SEE ANY DISCREPANCIES
OF WHAT HE TOLD US AND WHAT HE
CAME OUT PUBLICLY AND SAID.
>> SO IS DR. FAUCI WRONG?
>> BRET, I KNOW YOU ALL ARE
WORKINGOVER TIME TO TRY TO FIND
EXCUSES FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW FROM THE PRESIDENT’S OWN
WORDS, HE KNEW HOW SERIOUS THIS
THREAT WAS.
HE DID NOT IMPLEMENT THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO GET TESTING
TO WHERE WE NEEDED, CONTACT
TRACING TO WHERE WE NEEDED, TO
MOBILIZE PPE AND GET THAT AROUND
TO HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THIS PRESIDENT FAILED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN WE NEEDED
IT MOST.
>> I’M JUST ASKING YOU SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING THE PAST COUPLE DAYS.
JOE BIDEN HAS SAID AND YOU
MENTIONED IT THAT IF PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAD ASKED TWO WEEKS
EARLIER, 54,000 LIVES WOULD HAVE
BEEN SAVED IN MARCH AND APRIL.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTED TWO
WEEKS EARLIER AND SHUT
EVERYTHING DOWN, SUPER TUESDAY
PRIMARIES WOULD HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED.
WOULDN’T THEY?
MAKING IT HARDER FOR BIDEN TO
CATCH BERNIE SANDERS TO BECOME
THE NOMINEE.
YOU WEREN’T OUT CALLING -- HE
WAS NOT CALLING FOR THE STOP OF
THE SUPER TUESDAY PRIMARIES.
>> AGAIN, BRET, I’LL REMIND YOU
HOFF THE DISTINCTION I MADE
EARLIER THAT DONALD TRUMP IS THE
PRESIDENT.
>> HAD HE ACTED YOUR GUY MIGHT
NOT BE THE NOMINEE, CORRECT?
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT IT MIGHT BE
USEFUL TO LIKE ENGAGE IN
HYPOTHETICALS LIKE YOU’RE DOING.
DONALD TRUMP WAS THE PRESIDENT.
HE HAD THE INFORMATION.
HE LIED ABOUT IT.
IT’S THAT SIMPLE.
>> OKAY.
LET ME MOVE ON.
YOU HAD AN INTERVIEW TODAY, THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT DID.
HE TOLD JAKE TAPPER THAT HE
WOULD RAISE CORPORATE TAXES DAY
ONE REGARDLESS OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
ONE, IS THAT GOOD POLITICS AND
TWO, HOW WOULD HE DO THAT?
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CLEAR HE’S GOING TO STAND UP FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS, BE THERE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES AND PRIORITIZE
THEM IN EVERYTHING THAT HE DOES.
AS YOU KNOW, YOU COVERED THE
VICE PRESIDENT ROLLED OUT IN HIS
PLAN FOR AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
INVESTING
IN MANUFACTURING AND OUR
CAREGIVERS, INVESTING IN A CLEAN
ENERGY ECONOMY.
YOU KNOW, IT’S SOMETHING THAT WE
TALK OFTEN ABOUT.
IT’S ONE OF THE JOBS OF THE
PRESIDENT, TO GET AMERICANS BACK
TO WORK IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND THIS
PANDEMIC.
>> A LOT OF TIME TO GO INTO
SPECIFICS.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT NAFTA
AND WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THAT.
IT’S IMPORTANT IN A LOT OF
STATES.
I WANT TO KEEP IT FAIR ON
TIME.END WITH THIS.
HAS JOE BIDEN EVER USED A
TELEPROMPTER DURING LOCAL
INTERVIEWS OR TO ANSWER Q&A WITH
SUPPORTERS?
>> WE’RE NOT -- THIS IS STRAIGHT
FROM THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TALKING
POINTS.
>> THEY’RE USING IT.
>> WHAT IT DOES, BRET, IT’S
TRYING TO DISTRACT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> THEY’RE USING IT.
THEY TALK ABOUT IT EVERY DAY.
SAY YES OR NO.
>> THEY TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEY DON’T HAVE A COHERENT --
>> YOU HAVEN’T ANSWERED.
YES OR NO.
>> THEY TALK ABOUT IT EVERY DAY
BECAUSE THEY DON’T HAVE A
COHERENT ARGUMENT FOR WHY DONALD
TRUMP DESERVES RE-ELECTION.
HE LIED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND SHOWED LEADERSHIP AND
THEY’RE DESPERATE THEY CAN TO
THROW ANYTHING AGAINST THE WALL
FOR THAT FACT.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
YOU CAN’T ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> I’M NOT GOING TO ALLOW THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO FUNNEL THEIR
QUESTIONS THROUGH FOX NEWS AND
GET ME TO RESPOND TO THAT.